apparently you left it at uh boris at
your house or something other but that's
the story sadly for another time thank
you for watching we're back at 7 pm
tomorrow when we bring you all the fall
out from tonight's seismic vote up next
an extended special program of piers
morgan uncensored where peers will bring
you that vote you'll see me on it you'll
see kate mccann on it and of course the
vote itself thank you for watching
[Music]
well good evening this is pears morgan
uncensored for the next two hours an
extended version of our show because of
the massive breaking news tonight a
no-confidence vote in britain's prime
minister boris johnson you're looking
here at live footage from a helicopter
over the house houses of parliament
which tonight i can tell you are a
hotbed of intrigue gossip
backstabbing
malice revenge and just about everything
else you could possibly wish for in a
political bombshell moment and if you go
in even closer you will see the windows
of the 1922 committee room this is where
voting is probably just about finished
now
into the future of boris johnson this is
where
359 conservative members of parliament
have filed in over the last two hours
and cast their vote as to whether they
have confidence in boris or not though
they include by the way boris johnson
who's had to go and decide whether he
has confidence in himself as prime
minister which given what he did of
course with the eu referendum or
apparently he had a
yes and a no plan
maybe he went in and wasn't short of the
last minute do i have confidence in
myself
but either way we'll find out uh in
about an hour so about nine o'clock
it will be breaking news as to what's
happened and there are three scenarios
really boris johnson loses in which case
it's all over he's an ex-prime minister
and for that to happen 180 of his mps
will have had to vote against him or
he's won
comfortably with a stunning majority
that no one's expecting and he's saved
for at least another year because that's
the time limit on when you can then go
at him again if you're a rebel or what
is much more likely in my estimation but
we'll find out soon
is that he wins but not by very much and
that in in
many ways could be the worst scenario
possible for the conservative party
because that would mean this just
carries on for weeks months until
probably the inevitable departure of the
prime minister so those are the options
uh let's go to talk to me flightalon to
kate mcgann who's buried inside the
bowels of the palace of westminster and
in london bridge uh presented the news
test and of course tom newton done well
welcome to both of you look at you both
almost shaking with excitement kate kate
more than tom i have to say um because
it doesn't get much bigger than this
kate does it we are literally now 40
58 minutes away
from hearing whether boris johnson has
survived this vote although my gut
feeling and correct me if you feel i'm
wrong here is it's likely that he has
won the vote but it may be he's not won
it by convincing enough majority to
actually buy his safety
i think that's the real problem that
boris johnson faces now appears because
even if he does win this vote and his
advisers today briefing us that just one
vote is still a win that's enough for
them the reality is that that just isn't
true and when you've got mps like deanna
davidson coming out to say i can't back
boris johnson i voted against him that
is a real problem because that's not
somebody who's a usual suspect it's not
somebody who you expect to hear that
kind of thing from and it shows you that
there is a real there is a real division
there's some wavering some of that has
crystallized over partygate some of it
goes a little bit further back than that
and i think the big question is can
boris johnson do anything now if he wins
and we expect that he will to move his
party forward and that will largely
focus on policy some of that will be the
leveling up agenda but a lot of that
will be about taxation about the cost of
living crisis about the how the prime
minister moves forward now i have been
bradley here with me he's a conservative
mp
he's somebody who's very keen on the
leveling up agenda somebody who's been a
backer of boris johnson all the way
through this do you think he's done
enough tonight ben well i hope so um i
would like to think that colleagues like
danny you mentioned their other red wall
colleagues would recognize where the
votes came from in that 2019 election
because i think sometimes as mps we
maybe believe our own hype a little bit
a lot of those people in my constituency
too were voting for boris johnson in
that election and a lot of them still
will we all get uh emails from
constituents who feel very strongly even
in my oc 16 000 majority there's still
15 000 people who have never and will
never vote for me so i think we
sometimes need to recognize where those
dissenting voices come from the vast
majority of people that i speak to in my
constituency are very supportive who
said don't you dare let him go but there
is a real division in the party isn't
there and you know you mentioned deanna
there that does mean that this isn't
just a split of the usual suspects this
is a split that runs quite deep how is
he going to bring people back together i
think if you looked at diana's voting
record over the last couple of years
he's been fairly consistently
rebellious in some of these things
so not entirely a surprise but i think
there is a big job to do to bring us
back together we hope and the pm
certainly says he hopes that you get
through tonight and you draw a line and
you move on we'll see whether we're
allowed to do that but for the kind of
agenda we want to see that leveling up
agenda that affects constituencies like
mine we've absolutely got to keep them
and we've got to make it happen ben
bradley there saying that the right
answer is to keep the prime minister in
position he's hoping that the party can
come back together appears but i think
it is a real difficult task as you
mentioned there and that's what's going
to be well so exciting for political
journalists not particularly for number
10 over the course of the next couple of
weeks trying to see if he can manage
that task what is the key number here
kate tonight what are we looking for and
this result gets announced in you know
55 minutes what is the the key
figures you'll be looking at thinking
right he survived
obviously we know if he's lost but he
survived or the number of the majority
is low enough for this to still be
potentially terminal
it's a fantastic question piers and it's
one that nobody here agrees when you ask
them the answer to it i mean boris
johnson's own advisers say 180 is the
number he needs to reach that's when
he's effectively 180 plus one that that
would be a win for them that they would
see that as a success i have to say i
don't think anyone else would
necessarily agree with that they will be
looking for far higher maybe 220 to 30
to 40. when you start getting to 250 260
that's quite high that's quite ambitious
and i think what's happened this
afternoon this morning there was a
little bit of buoyancy from those around
the prime minister saying you know it'll
be fine i think there's a bit of
self-doubt creeping in and i know it's
not particularly helpful for you or for
anybody watching but there is a growing
sense that either boris johnson does
much better than expected and actually
the quiet ones have gone his way all the
quiet ones that we haven't heard come
out on twitter or make their views
public they go the opposite direction
and actually things are much much worse
than he expected i think in that case
then this is clearly a real problem even
if he does win by just one vote but
actually either way a confidence vote in
a prime minister is never a good thing
and it usually does spell the beginning
of the end even if it isn't immediate so
difficult either way i think and the
truth is a lot of those mps are
completely self-serving treacherous
little weasels who will be saying one
thing in public and quietly going in and
signing his death warrant
well look your word's not mine piers and
paul ben is still here he can he can
still hear what you're saying but um i'm
not saying he's a weasel i don't even
know
no don't worry i'll make sure he doesn't
think that um but look there are some
cabinet ministers i have to say who've
been out and about milling around here
behind me in central lobby throughout
the day today being very publicly
supportive saying the prime minister is
the right man for the job but behind the
scenes they have some real concerns some
of them saying to me look i don't
understand why he didn't do more over
the weekend to try and shore up support
for himself he apparently didn't make
very many phone calls didn't really make
much of an effort others saying yeah
look there is a really deep problem here
and of course those in the cabinet there
will be some of them who think maybe i
could have a little tilt at this so how
many of them when they got into that
ballot box of course the secret vote
will have thought maybe i'll just put my
cross in the no confidence box and see
what happens unleash a little bit of
chaos the difficulty i think for boris
johnson and your question really does
betray it is that actually his his
relationship with his party is
transactional and that transaction when
it benefits them it works if it doesn't
necessarily benefit them and those
by-elections are looming in the distance
if losses like that start to stack up
then that's a problem and i think that's
a big concept yeah i think the big
problem is they're looking at their own
positions their own jobs their own seats
and they're trying to calculate is this
guy going to lose me my job and if
enough of them calculate i think he
might
bang he's done it's as ruthless as that
okay we'll be back to you a little later
i can see your literally buzzing with
excitement down there
i'm talking about it with excitement
actually it doesn't look that exciting
this is downing street right now
covered with some old bunting from the
weekend um looks it looks sort of
ominously quite almost like a funeral
pyre this evening doesn't it um
very quiet very somber a car has pulled
up this could be anybody this could get
exciting who's this
no it's an uber driver it's uh it's his
evening pizza uh we don't know who that
is um
but let's go to lord marlon who was a
former minister uh instrumental in the
campaign to have boris johnson elected
as mayor of london uh and you think that
this shouldn't be happening at all lord
marlon why is that
i think it's shocking i i mean we have
all these major issues going on in the
world and the last thing we need now is
the conservative party self-destructing
before our eyes with bitter
argument and dispute
and uh throwing to the wind potentially
um a leader who's won them a massive
majority it's a it's a complete disaster
i mean he's also he's also the only
prime minister that you have described
he's the only prime minister ever to
have been served with a fine by the
british police for breaking a law and
indeed it's one of his own laws i mean
i just don't understand how any
conservative who believes in integrity
and property in high office could be
comfortable with that fact
well no one's comfortable with it in
fact it's a it's a shocking thing but
on the other hand i'm very comfortable
with the way that he's
led the world in terms of ukraine and by
the way
ukraine is being bombed at every moment
and you know he was on the on the
telephone today to their leader um
dealing with some very substantive
issues he's also had to deal with the
covet crisis he's had kovit himself he's
had to deal with brexit he's had all
manner of crises which actually by and
large he's handled extremely well
and of course you quite rightly say
there is public
uh disgust in the behavior at number 10
which isn't just him uh it is uh all
manner of civil servants and people who
are meant to support them and i feel
actually quite sympathy for these civil
servants because they've worked all
round the clock during the cobit crisis
well you feel sorry just to clarify
you're able to attack you feel sympathy
for them that they all broke the law
over 80 of them including the boss and
they all broke i don't know
i don't
no no
you're are putting words in people's
mouth no i don't feel sympathy for them
breaking the law at all i feel disgusted
by it as all of us do
but the fact is they have worked all the
right way around the clock no credit's
been given to that they've dug slightly
their own grave after performing a
magnificent task
um
and now they are reaping the whirlwind
i mean you make it sound like this was
the inevitable consequence of their hard
graph for the nation whereas i would
argue that they systematically in large
numbers broke the very laws that they
had laid down for the public which meant
for argument's sake to give one
illustration that her majesty the queen
whose reign we've just been celebrating
for four days had to spend the funeral
of her long long time husband and rock
prince philip on her own
because she felt a duty to obey these
lockdown rules laid down by downing
street and then it turned out that they
were not one but two illegal parties in
downing street the night before phillips
funeral and that's i think what has
incensed people is that they look at all
this they look cool the volume the
volume of parties the volume of people
working there who were fined by the
police they look at the prime minister
being personally fined himself and
they've drawn the conclusion that they
think this is brazen double standards
and hypocrisy and i want to play you the
clip just to remind you and the viewers
of what happened when boris johnson
finally came face to face with the
british public many of whom are royalist
monarchists likely conservatives this is
what happened on friday morning at
paul's cathedral
[Music]
i mean when that happens to a football
manager lord marlon they normally get
shown the door very quickly when their
own fans turn on them i mean it's a
concern
you couldn't possibly watch that with
anything but a shudder could you
no but also your friends the sussexes
got very heavily booed because they also
lost the support of the middle england i
i and
yeah and i was with
the royal family in the brain at the
braemar games when tony blair and cherie
blair were booed by the whole stadium
and in fact i had lunch with a friend of
yours today in both them who said i used
to get booed the whole time booing is
quite normal for prime ministers uh it
doesn't mean it's right and it doesn't
mean it's it's not the public venting
their ragna of course they're venting
their anger and justifiably so but the
question is do you want
do you want 12 weeks of the conservative
party tearing itself apart when in fact
they should be governing the country
and trying to get through these shocking
crisis that confront us
energy crisis
food inflation
cost of living crisis and of course the
horrendous war on ukraine which is uh
having the impact on our economy that uh
is widely reported that's my point it's
not the fact that he is right in doing
what he's done it's not the point that
he's right
that the civil servants are right in
what they've done i'm merely saying in
their case cut them a little bit of
slack but i quite understand that people
don't want to
what i'm saying is
is now the time to have this
election this 12 weeks
of
of bloodletting
is it in the benefit of the conservative
mps that want to do it because in the
end the voter will not put up with it
and the conservatives win the next
election and probably rightly so and
who is going to
deal with these crisis so be careful
what you wish for
well i guess we'll find out tonight
because he may he may well have already
lost for all we know my guess is he'll
win but the question is by what margin
and that margin i mean just finally for
you
what is the what is the tipping point
for you
what would he need to effectively win by
in terms of a small majority where you
would think his position's untenable
well i think history relates and your
reporter said it brilliantly earlier
that
most uh prime ministers who have this
vote of no competence against them
they find it very difficult to manage
the party thereafter i'm not saying
boris can't because he's got the energy
and the vision and actually he's got
that x factor that the public like and
they forgive him for an awful lot
but
clearly um
it's going to be over 100 i would have
thought that's the number
and uh
it's not going to be easy from him from
here on in
laurel marlon i appreciate you joining
me thank you very much indeed
thanks for having me on
well we've got adam bolton and tom
newton done uh with us now
adam bolton you've you've covered every
election for the last 460 years
uh
how much trouble is boris johnson in
it looks like he's in pretty big trouble
i mean all the signs from today's voting
are that things
haven't uh really gone his way there
hasn't been a strong uh number of uh
conservative mps coming out and
expressing their support for him and i
think what he was saying earlier on uh
appears about this possibly being more
of a shocker for him in terms of a
result is certainly the case and i think
if we get anything
near
to 50 50
in the vote even if he were to win by a
vote or two uh he would be uh finished
we've got i think
a hundred and fifty odd uh conservative
mps have said uh that they've voted for
him uh but we've also got some of team
boris coming out
and telling journalists after the vote
that tory mps are lying snakes
so
we shall have to see
what the result is obviously we're going
to know within the hour
but i think
this has gone extremely badly for boris
johnson i think the rapidity with which
uh the vote was called after the jubilee
they hope that would work in his favor
it doesn't look
as if it does so i think we are going to
see a prime minister uh mortally wounded
and remember uh if
uh a third of tory mps or more vote
against him
by the standards of his own team by the
standards of jacob rees-mogg at the time
of the vote which theresa may uh
suffered and lost only a third of her
mps he said that wasn't good enough she
should resign and i think mr rees-mogg
will be reminded very loudly uh of those
comments as indeed will boris johnson
who also implied at the time that she
should step down even although she uh
won technically
i'd just like to apologize to any snakes
that were offended by their comparison
to lying conservative members of
parliament uh i don't stay with us we'll
be with you all night it's gonna be very
exciting evening have a short break
we'll be back with our stellar panel
here i mean it doesn't get better than
these three look at this look at this
three beasts in the beauty we'll be back
after the break how dare you three
witches of macbeth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to a special extended
version of piers morgan uncensored i'm
joined now by tommy dunn from the news
desk tom i just want to talk to you
about potential successes should boris
johnson lose his job tonight or be
forced out in the next few months you go
off today a new poll if boris johnson
were deposed
who would conservative members want to
succeed him it was quite interesting i
thought a lot of runners and riders not
a clear favorite ben wallace was at the
top with 12 percent liz trust 11
jeremy hunt 10 percent penny more than 8
percent rishi sumac michael gove seven
percent pretty patel six percent tom
tuggenheim
so i mean really i would say
any one of those
with a spirited uh cantor
could actually end up as the leader it's
not clear cut at all
yeah i think you're right this is what's
so funny about this comments vote and we
were talking through on our program in
the last couple of hours as well is he
effectively got a leadership challenge
without an alternative leader in place
and i actually cannot remember a single
political contest going down the years
that's ever been the case even back to
you know thatcher hazeltine there was
hazeltine in the wings major redwood and
all the tory troubles sort of going
forward theresa may boris johnson was
always sitting there ready and waiting
so all i can say is if we do get a
leadership contest out of all this and
it's still is a big if i'm i'm i'm a
little bit on the offensive i think this
is 50 50. i would not put a single penny
on this going either way at the moment
but if we do get a leash contest it's
going to be absolutely intriguing
because what we'll have is the heart and
soul of the conservative audi poured out
all over the floor all over the walls of
our tv studios and everywhere else as
they absolutely thrashed out to really
not just define who's going to be leader
next but what it actually means to be a
conservative what an earth a
conservative party is supposed to look
like and shape up towards going into a
general election which is come next
sunday two and a half years away next
sunday marks exact midway point uh in
this parliament so you know all right
they've got two and a half years to to
go but actually electorally that's not
very much time at all it's not at all
fascinating thank you tom what's
bringing the panel um grace
how are you feeling right now because
obviously you can't stand boris johnson
are you presumably i don't feel that
much better about most members of the
conservative party to be honest and i
think what tom was just saying is it's
interesting and it's true you know i am
not 100 sure which way it will go it
obviously does seem very close perhaps
closer than we would have thought
earlier in the day um but
two weeks ago i think it was you and i
were sitting in the studio we were
discussing the su grey report um and
i think you asked me whether or not i
thought the boris johnson was going to
go and i said
he should go but i don't think that he
will go you know i don't think that he
really knows what accountability means i
think that he basically has been you
know spent his career in environments
where he's been able to get through
anything well if he loses he loses
tonight and it's interesting only 157 or
so tory mps have publicly declared their
support that's at least 20
fewer than at the same stage with
theresa may so whether that's
significant or not we don't know we
can't really trust them all um but
that is a pretty worrying indicator i
would say if you're if you're 10 downing
street tonight yeah and what tom was
just saying about how there's no clear
leader in place is a really important
point and what kate was saying about how
most of these mps see their relationship
with boris johnson as transactional
obviously that's true for you know most
any mp generally and their political
leader the issue is that transaction
goes both ways you know yes um you know
they need boris johnson and boris
johnson also needs them the question
that they have to then be asking is
what's going to happen when boris
johnson goes and as of the last election
the conservative party has been in this
state of you know division basically
between a group of mps who believe it's
their job to fight for the soul of the
conservative party as this kind of
free-market small state
austerity-driven project and those who
think oh actually we need to kind of
lose a little bit of that and go back to
you know perhaps some more investment
get rid of all this austerity baggage
and fight lots of culture wars in order
to broaden our coalition those two
groups are going to go at each other in
a very very fierce way regardless of
what happens in this country i mean we
saw it today isabel with nadine doris
immediately getting into a massive
public spat with jeremy hunt raising
some good points i have to say in her
tweet storm about his own record as
health secretary in failing to prepare
the country properly for a pandemic
but it was open civil war erupting on
social media right at the heart of the
conservative party this is going to be
the problem whoever tries to take over
you've got to somehow bring all these
factions together and you've got to
still maintain the remain
leave kind of you know
cliques that are going on it's not easy
you've got a rece potential recession
certainly surging inflation to deal with
this is this is a bit of a hospital pass
it almost always is though isn't it i
mean you mentioned the brexit thing
which we all wish that we'd kind of left
behind but you're absolutely right that
is now going to become a real problem
you know we've already seen
one of boris johnson's greatest critics
tobias elwood runs the defense select
committee reopening the question of
whether or not the uk should rejoin the
single market
now i thought his timing on that was a
little bit dangerous given his agenda is
to remove boris don't now bring in the
brexit thing because it allows downing
street right to try to argue that you
know this is all a big plot to unravel
brexit
jeremy hunt one of the key rebels also a
big remainer and i think that will
annoyingly for everybody who just wishes
that we you know this question had been
resolved and parked this is all going to
bubble up again yeah sharon
what do you make of this because at the
heart of it really is boris johnson and
his staff at downing street going
partying breaking brazenly their own
laws which everybody else had to follow
and the reason i think it's cut through
so powerfully with the public is that so
many of them were not allowed to go and
see dying relatives in hospital i know i
know people including some in my family
who couldn't go and see
people as they died from covered in
hospitals and then to find out the
people making these laws were basically
on the lash everywhere well it was like
caligula at number 10.
uh you know puking throwing wine up the
wall god only knows what was going on
but the thing is
he lied
he lied he lied and surely somebody in
his position knows it will truth will
always come out no matter how long it
takes it always comes out and you look
worse so own it that was his big big
mistake
you've just done it with boris he's lied
through his entire career as a
journalist and politician and he's
always seemed to
fail upwards so he got fired from the
times for inventing quotes he got fired
you know under michael howard for lying
about an affair and each time he's
saying become london mayor and then he's
become prime minister so the message he
gets to himself is actually lying
doesn't matter and i think that's what's
brought him down that's the past and the
thing is yes he's quirky and he's this
funny little character that
england loved for a while you know he's
this funny little guy but the thing is
the guy has no vision
what's what's the vision of the
conservative party where is it going
does he have it what's his long-term
old-fashioned country right but don't we
also want integrity in our prime
minister well of course we do but that
come on we're living in the real world
here everybody is too much to ask yes
everybody lies everybody does what they
have to do for power power we all know
what goes on
behind the doors but the thing is
what a the situation that this country
is in right now do you take the devil
you know or the devil you don't know
look he's not going to laugh
i would keep that nutter in
no i would i would keep him in the sand
i would keep him in until there's a
long-term plan for this country what are
they going to do about the economy what
are they going to do the issue is the
issue i think is once once trust is
broken with the british people very hard
to then trust that person i'd use him
to tell us how he's going to rescue the
country if i was a conservative mp i
would keep him in as well and the thing
that i would be thinking as a
conservative mp would be let boris fight
the next election probably lose okay but
it will be a hung parliament it won't be
there won't be a kind of stable
government for particularly long the
conservative party get their brief
period out of office they get to sort
their stuff out they can find the leader
and they get to decide what they're
doing let's take another look at let's
take a look at downing street if we can
let's see what's going on there because
it was really quiet earlier it's still
pretty quiet i guess they're all waiting
aren't they for this earthquake to erupt
in about 30 minutes that's when we're
expecting the result from sigre and
brady who's the chair of the 1922
committee we now believe that all the
votes have been cast and we know from
when theresa may went through this it
takes about an hour to count them and
then to prepare the results here's down
the street from above
still nothing happening
it's like a it's like a weirdly eerie
oddly no partying can you notice there's
no one out there on the lash tonight is
there
no partying with the prime minister
we'll get a little break come back and
talk briefly about the platinum jubilee
which now already seems a distant memory
of national unity and joy and
celebration didn't take boris long to
ruin that either we'll talk we'll talk
about that after the break we're
continuing breaking news coverage from
this dramatic night for british politics
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to pittsburgh and
uncensored you're looking over the top
of the houses of parliament tonight
where all hell is probably breaking
loose as we await the result of the no
confidence vote into prime minister
boris johnson i'm rejoined by talk tv's
international editor isabelle shot
socialist author grace bakery and the
talks host sharon osborne my mother's
just texted me for discussing the next
prime minister tonight and she is the
voice of middle england i might add
please mention rory stewart he would be
the only one in my eyes
he's not a member of the conservatory
conservative party
rory's too it's an incredibly impressive
guy and yet he doesn't factor why well
because he was a remainer he's basically
a lefty that's why i mean you know he
just doesn't really meet the core offer
of being a conservative yeah but if
middle england likes him oh yeah but
they like him like a kind of little pet
you know
i know he was didn't he jump across
afghanistan he liked all of that but you
know yeah not after he went it takes a
bit of moral fight
um we've got some mps that we've spotted
from our our helicopter we think they're
mps there might be completely random
strangers who've decided to go down and
gate crash the party but
there they all are they're all out there
obviously obviously partying which is
what we expect from our politicians now
they'll just be they'll all be plotting
not partying they'll be plotting out
there on the river trying to work out
what's going to happen here and we're
going to find out in about 25 minutes i
want to turn briefly to
the last four days of the platinum
jubilee sharon because
aside from boris johnson being booed
which may well have been a tipping point
for many mps to press the button on him
today with this no confidence uh it was
also interesting to me that the sussexes
got booed
uh harry and megan what did you make of
that well it wasn't a total boom it
wasn't as big as boris no nowhere near
very unusual for a member of the royal
family to get any booing at that kind of
event and they did but it wasn't
anywhere near as bad as boris you could
still hear the cheers above the booze
put it that way
i mean what should we read much into it
i just got the feeling they basically
discovered on this particular trip that
they've gone from a-list royals to
c-list and that's how the royal family
are now going to treat them they won't
be on the balcony they won't be at the
top events and they can come and go if
they want but they're no longer going to
be working a-list important royals
they have lost their importance they
don't mean anything the country um
wasn't that overjoyed
i didn't hear many people go this is
amazing the country really cares right
they didn't and and the thing that i
must say is the country didn't react one
way or the other it was oh they're here
okay
but
the way they kind of came in and went
was
uh a huge signal that i don't think
we'll see them here much and what made
me laugh isabel was they they arrived on
a massive private jet from california
these two economies wasn't constantly
a lot they've used the clooneys a lot
who know of somebody right but it's the
utter hypocrisy once again preaching
about carbon footprint always using
private jets every time so yeah i mean
funny the common link between all the
people who got booed was hypocrisy the
british public will forgive a lot of
things but they won't forgive brazen
hypocrisy to be fair on them they did
actually keep a relatively low priority
and you know you said they discovered
their seedless i mean they asked to be
taken off the list you know they
wanted to be out of the working
circulation so i i think it could have
gone worse you know i don't think they
overshadowed it
people took pictures of them but they
did behave quite well what has no impact
i want to make no impact
i just want to play a clip first of all
of the this is the queen on the last the
closing moments
of the platinum jubilee on sunday
because we weren't sure if she'd even
make it she was there at the start i was
by the palace when they when she came
out on the thursday it was amazing
moment and then she just sort of
vanished from sight and we thought that
maybe we wouldn't see her again and then
you suddenly saw the flag moving
on the palace roof and you realized
fantastic and then you thought go on
how'd you come and out came the star of
the show the star of any show she's ever
at and she came out and i just thought
if we can listen to a bit of the sound
here i just thought this was
so moving
[Applause]
that was a scene and then of course the
crowd had burst into god save the queen
which was incredibly evocative and
emotional i felt um it's about i mean
it's hard to overstate the importance of
this queen to this country or the impact
that we're going to have when she's no
longer here couldn't agree more i mean i
found i'm not a massive monarchist but i
found the whole thing weirdly moving and
it is because it sort of feels like it's
a bit of a goodbye uh i know that sounds
a little bit more kid what's the last do
you believe that we'd better have for
her in reality she is not well we know
that and you know when the palace says
she's experiencing some discomfort we
know that really means she's in a very
great deal of pain and i think when she
does sadly pass there is going to be a
huge amount of national soul-searching
you know she has held everything
together real concerns about the future
of the union and the commonwealth i
totally agree grace i know you're not a
massive monarchist in fact you spent
most of the weekend
according to your instagram feed at a
wild festival where you were painting
your fingernails fluorescent green
which i thought was a tribute to what
the queen wore actually on the sunday
night
clearly
but even as somebody's not that into the
monarchy can you appreciate what this
woman has done for the country
i have basically no opinions about them
as people i don't really follow you know
the ins and outs of the monarchy i don't
think i should have to follow what goes
on within this family this dynasty that
kind of rules our country from behind
the scenes what i do think though is
that when the queen does sadly die we
will enter into a national conversation
about whether or not this is an
institution that we should have as part
of our you know constitution as part of
the way that our country works it is
very strange that we have a family whose
you know uh marriages weddings births
dramas we're all constantly invested in
understanding so they're kind of
kardashians or something that they're in
charge of our politics of our government
ultimately this is our head of state i
think that when the queen who everyone
you know loves and who's been in charge
for a very long time uh does go when we
have this array of pretty uninspiring
potential successes people are going to
start thinking
right you are missing in my view the
rising superstar of the royal family and
it's this little guy he is louis he's
amazing who whose facial expressions
over the four days got increasingly
hilarious and who clearly began to seize
his moment and in fact the duke and
duchess of cambridge issued a statement
tonight on twitter thanking everybody
and saying that we all had a fantastic
time especially louis
[Laughter]
don't you think though that it it gave
people confidence that this is the
family that will be here after the queen
yeah it's nice
by the way very deliberately that last
scene on the last night and everyone was
singing god save the queen but she had
chosen for that sort of iconic moment at
the end of the picture that this was the
family she that this is now the
streamline the way it's royal these are
the two next monarchs potentially three
next monarchs and that's the way it will
be charles has said for a long time that
he's gonna cut down the people who are
actually on payroll and that represent
the family it's going to be cold and the
thing is i i think that the royal family
brings so much to this country
i mean you look at all the
people from all over the tourists i mean
i think they're taught
because they don't actually cost us
anything
i think we were going to make a kind of
coherent economic argument as to how we
construct our head of state we could
probably make a better one for saying i
don't know have a presidential system or
have one got our own version of joe
biden well i mean no it wouldn't be it
wouldn't be the same as that you would
have putting it out yeah
political editor harry cole joins me now
live from the heartland of westminster
harry good evening to you what's going
on do you know the answer yet
no one knows the answer they are
currently tallying up the votes i don't
quite understand why it takes an hour to
count 365 bits of paper but nevertheless
uh we should know very soon but i will
say the mood has gone a little bit flat
here and some of those prime minister
supporters who are looking chirpier this
afternoon are looking a little bit glum
right now whether that means they are um
you know expecting bad news or whether
they are just exhausted after a day
hammering the phones remains to be seen
and harry for you what is the tipping
point number where if he was to win the
vote but get such a small majority he
would really be in terminal trouble
look i think anything that sort of close
to 180 figure um is going to be very
hard work for even the the best spin
doctors in the world to spin and i i
think anything really around 150 140
even 130 rebels means that kierstama can
stand up every single pmq's for weeks on
end and say
more than a third of people behind you
hate you and want you gone yeah and you
just wonder
in the run-up to election is that really
viable of any prime minister and if he
isn't there anymore you know all the
betting today is quite interesting it's
sort of spread across the board i was
reading them out earlier uh you know ben
wallace the defense minister he's he's
ahead at the moment
is he somebody that you think could
potentially come through
well i think anyone in the cabinet is
going to find it quite tough to distance
themselves from boris johnson should he
be sort of the ceremonies normally
ousted um however at a time of of
where we are in the electoral cycle and
perhaps where we are with the situation
in europe with um
with the war in ukraine perhaps it
wouldn't be the first time that a
defense secretary would be in the
running that said i think there'll be
quite a few people on the tory back
benches who think actually you guys have
stuck with boris johnson all the way
through thick and thin maybe it's time
for some fresh blood and look to back
benches for for an untested mp but um i
have to say that's never happened in
really properly in british history
if boris johnson does lose or wins by
such a meager majority that he's
basically toast
what do you think harry has been the
thing that's done him in
no i think there's two factors one his
handling of the party gates uh saga as
it now is has been appalling i think if
he'd come out early on and said it would
have been very painful but came out and
said you know what we we we didn't think
it at the time but it we probably did
break the rules and groveled and
grumbled rather than sort of having eeks
out of him for months i think would be
an issue the other problem is for boris
johnson everyone thinks oh he's a
relatively new mp he's only been on the
front line for three years if you think
back he's actually been at the forefront
of british politics for 17 years now
and you know he has been a marmite
figure all the way through even when he
was mayor of londoner people that hated
him brexit obviously
galvanized that marmite-ness around him
and actually you have to wonder he's a
very lucky general at times but even a
cat runs out of lives at night
and to be honest i rather like marmite
characters myself so
i always think there's hope for marmite
imagine
harry thanks for now i appreciate it uh
entrepreneur charlie mullins has joined
us in the studio charlie what do you
make of all this should boris johnson
stay or go
well i think i think he's going to stay
i think um i don't think the votes are
going to go totally against him i think
he's going to be very close but um
whether he's going to resign after that
or not but i think he's going to win
this evening but should he go of course
he should go why well because of the
morally it's wrong what he's done there
and i don't think anybody's got any
faith in him now and publicly just had
enough of it all i mean i get that
feeling when i saw the booing going on
at supports cathedral i just thought
that was that was middle england really
saying you know what we're just done
with you because it's it's been constant
yeah i mean you said about the buoyant
but he was smiling that he thought they
were shouting out booze right you know
but you're right
it's not they were saying
yeah but you know i think that uh he's
brought this on himself and and
what are all your friends and employees
that you've spoken to make of it oh well
everybody's just sick and tired of it
and they just really want someone there
that could be honest someone they can
trust someone hopefully that can you
know become a much better leader and win
the next election i mean if he stays i
don't think he's going to get out voted
tonight but if he does stay i think that
it can't be far from him stepping down
everything he's got more people against
him now than theresa may and you know
you know what happened well she stepped
down more importantly what was it like
performing sweet caroline at the uh
platinum jubilee i've done it quite bad
didn't i
thought you were a great rod yeah yeah
yeah
funny enough roster i came out with a
great line the other day i'm just
obviously comparing you to the great man
because i'm sure you like the comparison
but um he was saying the other day that
only he and the queen they've got one
thing in common they've had the same
haircut for 60 years
[Laughter]
um yeah not not quite 50 years for me
but yeah are you a roster of that well
what do you think well of course you are
you must hope
waiting and wondering
is he toast he could be gone tonight
pretty dramatic so stay with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to facebook sensor
this is inside the 1922 committee room
this is where it's all happening tonight
the 359 conservative mps have now
registered their vote as to whether they
have confidence in boris johnson that
number includes boris johnson himself
who had to decide whether he had
confidence in himself and to join now by
its capable former leader liberal
democrats great to see you
looking i have to say extremely rested
tanned
full of energy is that what happens
after you stop being a leader yeah
retirement
[Laughter]
what do you make of all this what's
going to happen do you think in terms of
i'm a bit i'm unfashioned by my viewers
i i think boris will win probably and i
suspect his supporters
brought this division on they could have
waited a few weeks
but now it's probably the best time to
have it there's some bad news coming
down the road
there was momentum building up against
him so have the vote now take it on
and then he's got a year's grace
probably um and you know we know he's
he's a mouth you know he's a politically
very clever guy great communication
skills
he can possibly turn it around well he's
the ultimate slippery eve yeah
every time you think something's going
to stick to him off his slides and he
just barrels on which in a way is a
political skill no i would would have
some money on him actually would you
yeah interesting grace i mean he could
he could just come through this stronger
than ever because of course if he comes
through with a reasonable majority he'll
claim complete vindication he'll say
partygate is now officially over the
rebels have tried they will have to back
off they're going to have to you know
just suck it up for at least a year
unless they change the rules which i
think is unlikely so boris would live to
fire another day that could happen it
could and i think boris himself has
learned that he can basically come
through almost anything he can lie he
can get attacked he can come through
scandals and survive um i think partly
that probably stems back to his
upbringing you don't go to eaton and
oxbridge and come through the british
establishment without knowing a little
something about how to kind of come
through scandals but i also think it is
just the fact that he has come through
so many now he seemed able to lie
throughout his career he seemed able to
i mean really if you look back over the
last several years of the conservative
party of this government it's not just
been the party gate scandal we've had
the green cell scandal which in my
opinion was far far worse it exposed
kind of corruption at the heart of the
british state you had all this stuff
about his wallpapers you had everything
that was going on during um the pandemic
you've got now the massive cost of
living crisis which really should be
what we're talking about and he has just
been able to basically cast all of this
off and consistently
you basically start culture wars throw
you know new stories onto the table
throw dead meat to journalists and say
let's fight about something rather than
talking about the issues that matter and
it could work again isabel i mean is he
basically our version of donald trump
now where truth isn't that important to
his political success because people
factor in
that he's a you know that he's pretty
loose and free with it well that's sort
of what sharon was saying earlier and
but i think the scales of lying isn't
there and you know this man is a
pathological liar and at some point i
think the voters become repelled by that
on the issue of the rules
the possibility of them being changed
that's not as distant as you might think
there are an elections elections coming
up for the 1922 committee they actually
have it in their gift to change the
rules so that year that he's supposedly
saved for come september that might not
look quite so okay
let's go to talk tv's political editor
kate mccann again kate uh we're
literally maybe four or five minutes
away now from getting this result are
you getting any more feeling
about where it may go or are we all
literally in the dark here
well everybody is literally in the dark
because the only person who knows is
segregated brady who's the chair of the
1922 committee my understanding is that
he was going to drop the prime minister
a line just before he announces that
result at nine o'clock so the pm can be
aware of exactly what's happening i
think it's fair to say as harry was
saying to you just before piers it's
fairly jittery here things have got a
bit louder people have started to come
to camera points to react to that vote
but you know number 10 sources saying
that the reaction of deanna davison we
were talking about her earlier on the
red wall mp who's
said tonight that she is going to vote
against the prime minister she's going
to vote no confidence that that was a
bit of a wobbly moment that that has
worried them slightly they are now very
concerned about what other mps might do
other so-called quiet mps who haven't
been as public about their views they
thought they could rely on her clearly
they couldn't and may well be more the
same they're saying for what it's worth
that two-thirds result so two-thirds of
the party backing the prime minister
would be a pretty good result for them
but also admitting behind the scenes
that anything
lower than that any less than two-thirds
of mps backing the prime minister is
going to look very difficult indeed i
think there are wild ranges when it
comes to uh how this is going to play
out for him but anything 150 180 is
starting to look quite tricky i mean
i've got vince cable here he's very
bullish on boris he's he's says that
he'd put money on him surviving and
thriving
well look i think i think that's
probably fair i think vince cable's
probably right the prime minister may
well win this vote and he may well go on
to move forward as the leader of the
conservative party as the prime minister
but i think there is a question now
about whether this is the beginning of
the end because remember those two
by-elections loom they are not far away
the promise he made today to his mps in
the 1922 committee i'm a winner i can do
this again if you back me better times
are still to come well if they lose
those two by-elections that's going to
look very difficult and we've been
talking all day long about the fact the
1922 committee rules say if he wins this
vote tonight he's safe for a year well i
wouldn't back money on that because the
1922 committee earlier this year
discussed changing the rules so you
could have two votes one every six
months they could well do that if they
want to because as i say it's convention
not rules vince cable i mean you're a
betting man and you would bet that he
will survive this and and carry on
but should he it's a different question
no from a national interest point of
view no i mean the reasons you set out
earlier you know you've lost the trust
of the public you've made laws and not
followed them you know you've treated
the public as idiots i mean i think for
the holy see of public standards and
ethics the answer is no but in terms of
the conservative party i mean he may be
the best that they've got i mean he
shouldn't he's holding this coalition
together right but should any serving
prime minister who is fined by the
police
in this country for breaking his own
lockdown rules should any prime minister
survive even that moment no and you know
from the wider public interest obviously
the answer is no but this is not what
the vote's about and they're choosing
the best leader that they can produce
and you know he does hold this
conservative coalition together it's not
it's not at all clear who can do better
what happens if he survives this
and then we discover that shakir starm
and angela rainer get fined by the
police for what they did with the curry
and the beers and they've already
pledged to resign well he he may well
and that actually in a strange way may
help the labour party i mean stan has
done his work he's detoxified it he's
got rid of the corbett knights and they
may and there are quite a few very
talented people mainly women on their
front bench who could a bit more
charismatic than he is so actually that
may not be a bad outcome for labour so
it could help the party um let's we've
got six seconds away now from minecraft
we were told to expect the result at
nine o'clock
so here's big ben
right at the heart of our parliamentary
democracy it is
906 seconds
and there's nothing come on say graham
brady you've tormented us all evening
where are you man maybe it's a tie
oh vince cable raising the specter of it
being a tie which would be unthinkable i
have no idea what happens in that
eventuality but the the reality is we're
now watching
live scenes from parliament and the 1922
community we are waiting to hear the
result people are back in this looks
like so graham brady has got his result
and we're about to hear it let's go live
and just listening good evening
i can report as returning officer
uh that 359
ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
theater was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
[Applause]
well there's a result it's 211 in favor
of boris johnson but 148
conservative mps voted against their own
prime minister tonight which i would say
is an incredibly high number let's go to
adam bolton adam your take on that
result
well that's 58
uh of the votes in favor of boris
johnson uh so that clearly
is just a little bit better than mrs
thatcher when she was forced out on 55
but it's considerably worse than theresa
may
who got 66
of the votes cast and remember uh jacob
rees-mogg the cabinet minister now uh
said then that that was not a vote of
confidence uh that she should resign uh
it's also less than john major got so
this is a bad result uh for boris
johnson of course he lives to fight
another day
and he probably of his predecessors
thatcher major or may is
more inclined to try and fight it out
but obviously 148 is bad news i mean we
were hearing earlier on from the boris
johnson camp that they were hoping to
keep the number of rebel mps below uh
100 well they've
failed by a factor of 50 on that
uh so
what happens next it looks like mr
johnson will struggle on it looks like
uh there's going to be this issue of uh
what happens to kierstama and angela
rayner if they resign that will clearly
put pressure on him uh given his own
behavior then we could have those
by-elections and if he loses both of
those uh conservative mps will uh appear
to have gambled on a loser and of course
at the end of this uh if he's still
there uh once the standards committee
has looked into this there's the whole
question of whether he lied it to
parliament so it looks to me as if we're
going to get the continuing agony
of boris johnson and uh it does seem to
me that with uh
you know a third of his party not
backing him more than a third of his
party uh uh not backing him uh 40 in
fact that uh you know he is heading
towards
a very difficult few months and it's
very unlikely that he'll be able to move
on and concentrate on all that
government business his loyalists keep
on telling us about but he will stay
right let's just for recap then so 359
conservative members of parliament voted
tonight and the vote of confidence in
the prime minister here's the result
from sigre and brady
i can report as returning officer
that 359 ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
leader was 211 votes and the vote
against was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
let's go to vince cable vince i mean i
would say 148 of his own mps varying
against him that's not a good night for
boris johnson surely it's not a good
night except he has survived and and we
know that this very unlike the the
theresa may
dissidents who were united who knew what
they wanted and were were very organized
and committed his opponents in his own
party are very fragmented there's no
clear alternative so he has survived and
i would expect he will continue
surviving maybe bad news for the country
it's i think it's good news for kirsten
murray and david i mean they've they've
never because they're going to go out
they've got a wounded opponent now i
mean davey's emerging
the sort of knight in shining armor of
british politics isn't he the only
untouchable it's not been tarnished by
partygate at all well
indeed yeah i mean isabel
give me a snapshot reaction to this
result i think it's the worst possible
result actually for the conservative
party certainly for the country a great
result for the labour party because this
now this agony will go on and on and on
any idea that this has somehow put the
issue to bed is absolutely for the birds
think of all those people that have
publicly come out today within the tory
party for the first time blistering
letters of no confidence you can't take
that away they've put it in writing
that's not going to suddenly kind of
evaporate because there's been some kind
of consensus there isn't a consensus
here it's just a majority and not a good
one at that grace you know it seems to
me if you were using a shipping analogy
the boat has been hold
and we're just not quite sure how
quickly it's going to
tumble to the bottom of the ocean yeah i
mean i think as i said before boris
could quite easily not easily but he
could conceivably stumble through this
he could protect himself he could
basically just carry on as though
nothing has happened get to the point of
the next election um be confident in the
fact that there's no clear successor to
replace him that as um vince was saying
that his opponents are not united
whether or not this does actually end up
being good for the labour party is i
think a big question here because we're
going to have effectively several years
of non-government it's unlike all the
news is going to be uh confined to
what's going on within the tory party
and then the stuff that they chuck out
to keep us busy chatting whilst they go
about their business the question is can
labor construct a narrative about where
we should be going because kirsten has
not done that effectively thus far so
unless he can actually say what should
we be doing right now where should we be
going as a country how should we be
solving the cost of living crisis then
it's not actually going to benefit labor
we could end up going back to a
situation like we had before 2018 of
just hung parliaments and constant kind
of procedural i mean if you are labor
though you might be thinking yourselves
let's just keep boris there because that
might be the best chance we ever win in
the election uh joining me again is talk
to me political editor kate mccann who's
with tory mp and forest supporter mike
wood
i am piers i have to add just on those
numbers you're having a really
interesting chat there with adam about
them remember there were around 174
people on the payroll so who essentially
paid or had an advantage to backing
boris johnson if you take a look at
those numbers with the number who have
eventually supported him that only is
around 35 additional that's not great
for the party so as you say let's ask
mike wood about that because he is here
with me mike you obviously do support
the prime minister you can't be very
happy with these numbers are you well i
think i said before you that beforehand
because i thought that anything more
than 210 would be a solid result 211 is
obviously in line with that it's the
majority the party will say that in
order to replace a leader you need a
majority voting to have no confidence
instead it's a clear majority saying
that they have confidence in boris
johnson to remain leader of the
conservative party and now he does need
to
get back to focusing on those important
issues facing the country and the world
at the moment it's a pretty whopping
number though it's well over a third
higher than most people expected the
party were saying this morning they
wanted to keep it under 100 rebels they
haven't managed that by a long shot how
on earth is boris johnson going to bring
people back together now well kate you
you were here at the time in the last
leadership election you remember on that
fifth ballot when it was blindingly
obvious that boris johnson was going to
be in the final two he still only got 51
percent of conservative mps he got 160
conservative mps voting for him in that
fifth ballot at a time when he was
clearly going to be in the uh final two
so he's he's built there's a further 51
who have supported him tonight
on top of the numbers
if the prime minister says that he's had
a good pandemic he's made all the big
calls right it's not really great to
only have added that number of mps and
when over a third of your own party
still think he's the wrong man for the
job well no i i think it's clearly over
over half of voted that they want him to
remain as leader of the conservative
party and as and as prime minister there
are really big issues facing the country
at the moment that go
well beyond some of the issues that have
obviously been raised
over the last few weeks we need the
prime minister to be supporting people
with the cost of living as he has been
doing we need him to be continuing to
lead the western world in resisting
russian aggression in ukraine and we
need him to be focusing on helping our
businesses our schools and our nhs to
rebuild after the covid pandemic that's
the important work all the things that
we're elected to do in december 2019 we
need to build on that progress remind
people why they voted for a conservative
government with a clear majority and i
know that boris johnson is the best
leader of the conservative party to
deliver on that and the best person to
lead the country going forward mike wood
thank you very much there you go pierce
that's the argument of conservative mps
tonight mike wood at pps there now uh
producer victoria is just going to nip
in and get anne marie trevillian who is
the trade secretary mike's up so uh if
you want to have a quick chat to her
because what's really interesting now is
this number of mps this this scale that
was above what the party was really
hoping to see 148 that means that the
next couple of days and the next couple
of weeks are going to be really
difficult for the prime minister we saw
a hint of that today he was talking in
the 1922 committee about a potential
announcement on tax cuts about focusing
on policy going forward but i think
things are going to get very difficult
for him now and anne-marie trevelyan
joins us here anne marie de valiant you
are the trade secretary you're in boris
johnson's cabinet
how does it feel tonight to know that
that many of your own mps don't support
him
so uh i'm glad that we are the other
side of the vote i know that the prime
minister spent all day listening to
those police who had those concerns and
he will have heard from them where those
areas of policy were that they feel he
needs to focus on and as you say there
are some really big areas of policy that
we want to drive forward
both in the energy revolution and
infrastructure investment really
importantly tackling the cost of living
crisis and making sure that we bring
forward policies that make a difference
to all our constituents day in day out
there is so much to do obviously we were
elected on a very broad manifesto in
2019 the challenges of kobit and uh the
emergency situation that we have seen
within the prime minister led not only
the uk and delivering a vaccine but the
world in finding solutions demonstrating
that he has that incredible capacity to
push through in really hard situations i
know that tomorrow morning he will be
drawing together all those thoughts and
really putting forward a package of
measures and policy direction which are
going to help the uk really move forward
at pace i'm really excited so does that
mean tax cuts next week then i wouldn't
dare speak on behalf of the chancellor
of kate you know that would be a an
absolutely death sentence for anybody
but i hope very much that we will see uh
the treasury looking across the piece
and broadly forwards how we can drive
forward what is a conservative a clear
conservative policy framework always
which is to make sure that we leave as
much of our hard-earned cash in the
pockets of those who've learned it
that's always been a concept philosophy
and we need to make sure that we pay
down some of the costs we've had to pick
up through kobed but i know that the
chancellor prime minister will want to
drive that forward in due course i know
that you're here in support of the prime
minister i know that you're going to say
that he's doing the best job and that he
can move forward from this but the
reality is going to be really really
difficult do you honestly believe that
boris johnson can bring this fractured
party back together and fight the next
election yes i really do because he has
always demonstrated that when we're in
really difficult circumstances where
there are many many competing forces he
has an extraordinary clarity uh he has
an ambition he has a bold perspective
and he has a confidence in the british
people which is reciprocated from them
and i know that going forwards now this
has passed this voters pass he will want
to pick all that up and drive forward
make sure that we are delivering for all
those who voted for us back in 2019. and
marie trevelyan thank you so much for
joining us tonight
sophia it's interesting to hear the
views of the cabinet and the fact that
anne marie turellian is saying now that
boris johnson has the confidence of the
country but he doesn't necessarily have
the confidence of all of his mps i think
it's going to be a watch and wait and
see how he makes it through the next
couple of weeks yes i think it certainly
is thank you kate let's bring back adam
bolton adam quick question given the
scale
of rebellion here you know 42 percent i
think it is of conservative mps have
voted against the sitting prime minister
could a senior cabinet minister with
leadership ambition
break ranks and resign and what pressure
would that put on boris johnson if that
was to happen now
well i suspect if they were going to do
it they should have done it today uh
rather than after the result
it's possible uh that uh members of his
cabinet might go to him and say look the
game's up we haven't got the support of
two out of five or you haven't got the
support of two out of five
of your parliamentary party but it has
to be said there's absolutely no sign
that they are going to do that because
what mr johnson has done very
successfully
going through all the way back to brexit
and then his own leadership has managed
uh to
govern
in a relatively uh determined way
with a very narrow margin of support uh
within the country or within his own
party and it looks like he's going to
continue to do that and frankly i can't
think of the person
in the cabinet
who's going to stand up and not want to
go in his slipstream i mean the closest
we came to it today uh was jeremy hunt
uh saying he wasn't going to support him
uh and uh i mean i think it's worth
remembering that the day started not
just with knowing that we're going to
get a vote but also with the former
treasury minister jesse norman uh
writing not about the parties but about
covenant current policy and describing
uh current uh boris johnson policy as
grotesque illegal ugly uh provocative
and unnecessary
so they're obviously a significant
minority and we must stress they are a
minority uh within the parliamentary
party who are extremely unhappy with the
direction of government uh and uh who
having come out in the open now uh and
shown that this uh
number of mps uh don't like what the
prime minister is doing i think they
will feel just as uh the pro-brexit
rebels felt during the teresa may time
uh that they have open license uh to
rebel on any government policy they
don't like right and significantly i
think with mr norman and his excoriating
letters he's married to kate bingham who
was boris johnson's savior with the
covid vaccine program so this is about
as ferocious as friendly fire gets i
would think uh adam thank you for now i
want us to remind people who are tuning
in uh 359 conservative mps have voted
tonight about whether they have
confidence in boris johnson 211
said they do 148 42 of tory mps no
longer have confidence in their prime
minister which is a pretty startling
number albeit boris johnson has won the
vote so we'll be back after the break
with more analysis and more reaction on
this big breaking news tonight stay with
us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to piers morgan
uncentred an extended version of the
show tonight to cover the big breaking
news on boris johnson and this vote of
no confidence but it turned out there
was a bit of confidence in him and not
as big a vote as he would have liked so
here's the result
i can report as returning officer
that 359
ballots were cast
no spoiled ballots
that the vote in favor
of having confidence in boris johnson's
leader was 211 votes and a vote against
was 148 votes
and therefore i can announce that the
parliamentary party does have confidence
well i'm joined now by former
conservative mps and whitaker and
subaru join me now welcome to you both
and whitaker your response to this
result
well i now hope very much that the
rebels will accept that they've lost and
not do
what otherwise they might do
which is to continually rebel on votes
in the commons make his life difficult
they've got he's got a year he's got a
year's grace and that will bring us
almost to the gates of a general
election and it's crucial now that the
party puts this behind it and pulls
itself together if you ask me peers will
they do that frankly i wouldn't bet on
it no i mean you've got to say though if
42
of conservative mps have no confidence
in a conservative prime minister
why on earth would anyone want him to
stay to fight an election i mean he's
going to get completely shellacked isn't
he the labour party running that that
result every two minutes
well every everything as i've said just
depends now uh what the reaction not of
boris is but of the party is kierstarma
doesn't have to oppose at the moment he
can just sit there and watch us lose
because that is what is happening
uh and i as i say it is down to the
party they've lost yes there was a large
vote a much larger vote than is
comfortable uh for having no confidence
but they have lost and the party's got a
straight choice if you if it wants to
win the next election then it's got to
go cohesively over the next two years
and if it doesn't it will lose and it's
no good then blaming boris can blame the
rebels anna sobry i mean when theresa
may went through all this several years
ago she actually won a much bigger
percentage of the vote two-thirds i
think it was and she was still gone
within a few months boris johnson has
not even scaled the dizzy heights of
theresa may's numbers what does that
mean for him
oh this is a big blow
big blow and remember you know credit to
boris johnson because he's been
he was the leader in 2019 when he got
that
big
huge majority biggest majority since the
days of margaret thatcher and yet in
a really short period of time because of
course we've had two years of the
pandemic so it's not been normal times
he now finds himself in this position
and i think he's toast
there's no way back for him but when you
just to clarify how does he become toast
because it's this is if you if you have
any
time for johnson at the moment you will
have voted in favor of him and there
will have been conservative mps who
would have given him if you like the
ballot the the benefit of the doubt but
have such a huge number
especially on your back benches because
there's this thing called the payroll
that's people who've got government jobs
who you would expect to be loyal to the
prime minister because they're members
of his government it's those back
benches and you know they go right
across um the the party the different
wings of the party um and so slowly more
and more people you know it's natural
they want to be on the winning side and
they will see the winning side as not
being boris johnson and remember we
haven't even had the two by-elections
that are due on june the 23rd both of
which are going to be really bad news
for boris johnson so he's now
contaminated by the stench of impending
political death and everyone will be
keen to avoid it but and would it come
if it's not boris johnson as people keep
asking then who should it be who do you
think would make a good leader of the
conservative party and therefore right
now a good prime minister
well i think one of the reasons that he
has retained the confidence of the party
or of the majority of the party is that
there obviously is no successor but
no obvious successor nobody waiting in
the wings as he was when theresa was
under pressure
but as i say you know there are two ways
to lose the election
uh one is uh to actually
just fall apart which is what is going
to happen if they go down the anna subre
course and just make his life difficult
if they fall apart they will lose the
election the other way to lose it is
quite simply uh to have the wrong leader
at the wrong time uh and as far as the
party is concerned now it's got to
decide that it's got to make boris the
right leader they're only there because
he was the right leader he still can be
but he's got to get a grip appears he's
got to get a grip not only on the party
on downing street on his operation on on
just the shambolic nature
of trouble the trouble is you know i
interviewed him
here's the trouble i'll come to anna on
this i mean i interviewed him for gq
years ago
and i said to him you know boris he
wasn't even london mayor then i said
look
i always tell people who think you're
just a buffoon that beneath the buffoon
exterior lies a brilliant calculating
ambitious political mind and he looked
at me and he said well piers you really
must consider the possibility that
lurking beneath the buffoon exterior is
a complete buffoon
uh and the trouble is i think for boris
johnson is the buffoon act
i think a lot of people are sick of it
because they're suffering financial
hardship they see the hypocrisy over the
party gate and they're just like you
know what i'm just done with having a
buffoon a guy who lies
you know every day of his life no one
can trust him and you can kind of skate
through
a political career like that when times
are good but when times are hard like
they are now i just think it's
unsustainable
um well the fact is he's got the
confidence sorry
both your names begin with the same
three letters i'm going to go to hannah
subery on that one to avoid confusion
and then come back to you ann whitaker
what what
piers what can i say because you're
absolutely right and i look i i'm not
involved in politics anymore i don't
live in london i live in the east
midlands which is where i was born and
bred and
seriously genuinely people are feeling
exactly what you've just said they're
just sick and tired of boris johnson and
it's all well and good for people like
anne william to say oh he needs to
change this the
problem is boris johnson if if the
conservatives want which they don't to
lose the next election keep boris
johnson if they want to win the next
general election the the only hope they
have is that they get rid of boris
johnson but i agree with anne the
alternatives are pretty ghastly too what
a mess the tory party's got itself into
and it's primarily got itself in that
mess because too many of the good people
were basically turfed out by boris
johnson and his crew back in 2019 it's a
very different party to the one that
even when anne was in
uh in the house of commons it's shifted
to this nationalist populist right wing
and it
it's dreadful and it's bad for our
country all right final word to
anwodicum
yes there is a choice now
carry on trying to get rid of forest
carry on being factionalized carry on
being divided carry on with all manner
of antics in the house of commons and
lose the next election
or just now calm down accept the result
and get on with it i just wish they'd
get on with it
do you know what i wish is i wish well i
i just wish we had more people like you
in the house of commons a pair of you
because you're always very lively very
smart takes on these things so i just
wish that that's what i personally wish
but thank you both for joining me
it's nice thank you
well i'm reading about my panel and uh
esther crack is joining us the
conservative commentator you're not
happy ah i'm horrified i think this is
just a terrible decision i think this is
a stain on the conservative party that's
just never going to go away i know ann
was saying that you know
the party must be united now or lose the
next general election i don't think
there is a conservative party that can
win with boris at the head of the next
general election i personally will not
vote for boris i would rather vote for
green i would actually rather vote did
you vote for him last time yes and i'd
actually rather vote for this chair i'm
sitting on than to vote for him i'm so
disgusted he represents everything i i
dislike about politics right now the
lack of integrity the lying the the
arrogance just it's just horrible and if
you're an actual decent conservative mp
and you're getting horrific letters from
your constituents saying i can't believe
this is what your party's chosen to do i
can't believe that you are my mp and
you're backing this man it's horrible
because they're people in politics that
genuinely want to do good and you can't
do good with someone like this at the
head i mean he should have a sense of
dignity and resign really and we've been
saying this right he should but he won't
and the fact that you know obviously the
vote was still significant in in the
form of the minorities who are not happy
with him but i don't think this is
enough he should leave isabel here's the
interesting thing about boris johnson is
however grim it always looks somehow he
wriggles out you know my oldest son's
been tweeting away in the last two hours
jubilant that he's won loves boris
because he ended locked down before most
other countries um you know at the end
of this last year um i think so we've
got this completely overblown he's a
great character and we should all be
queuing up to thank him i mean you are a
very special family pleaser
full of unique characters needless to
say i don't agree with him but it's
interesting but i think a lot of young
people have i mean the polls today show
there's a generational issue about boris
young people find him a bit of a laugh
and don't really care about party gate
probably because most of them are
breaking the rules themselves and then
you get everyone over 50 who was abiding
by the rules pretty much
who made a lot of sacrifices maybe
couldn't see dying friends and relatives
who really feel very strongly about it
well i mean under 50s don't tend to
particularly vote conservatives i'm not
sure how much their sort of ambivalence
is going to really work in favor of the
tory party anyway i mean i watched
esther what you said there play out at
an event on the isle of wight over the
weekend which is a very in theory a very
tory constituency big big safe seat for
the sitting mp
and i watched a live audience in front
of a a recorded program
the hostility towards boris johnson was
spilling over into hostility to the
sitting mp who on the face of it has
done nothing to deserve that and that is
what they're going to continue to get
and that's why this is not going to go
away because i don't think that voters
are suddenly going to say this is all
fine now you know let's all pull
together i suspect that boris johnson
will try and do a reshuffle pretty soon
one has been looming for a while he will
try to regain his authority by moving
the pack around a bit will it work
not unless you're getting even sick of
people saying that the country doesn't
really care about this we want to move
on how dare you tell
this country what we care about this is
a man who locked us down who told us we
couldn't leave our houses to do certain
things we weren't able to go to weddings
we weren't able would see dying
relatives and he fl he
blatantly broke those rules himself and
we're being told that we don't actually
care about that that's obscenely
offensive what it means is you don't
care that politicians
put laws on the rest of us and then
completely ignore them if you don't care
about that i'm not sure what you do care
about yeah you basically don't care
about the rule of law but funny enough i
interviewed the recently deposed prime
minister of pakistan imran khan
today i had a long interview with you
which will air later in the week but
what was really interesting was he
blames corruption in pakistani politics
for what happened to him and how he got
unfairly done in he can obviously try
again i think to to get his power base
back but he was very interesting about
the rule of law
in the uk
and the system that we have for holding
politicians accountable i don't know if
we've got the clip have we okay we're
getting we're getting the clip but i
thought it was interesting talking to
him because you're thinking
in someone like pakistan corruption is
rife they don't have a system like uh
we've got to hear this is this is imran
khan today
uh prime minister having a a drinks
get together after work would not even
have made news here in one way
this is one thing which i
feel that the reason why british
parliamentary system works
whereas
apart from
non
anglo-saxon countries it doesn't work
because of the very high
level of moral standards you expect from
your leadership in pakistan you know the
vote of no confidence against me which
took place
the whole country knew that the going
rate to buy my parliamentarians was a
million dollars unless we raise our
level of morality to what you have in
britain
parliamentary democracy will not work
i thought it's really interesting uh
we're going to come back after the break
and grace i'll just pick up on what
imran khan said there you're watching
extended breaking news coverage of the
boris johnson uh no confidence vote
turns out that some mps have confidence
in it and some of his mps don't uh so
he's won but it may be a correct victory
stay with us
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
welcome back to our breaking news
coverage of the boris johnson confidence
vote which he has won
uh 359 conservative mps voted 211 voted
uh to have confidence in him continue
continues prime minister 148 a large
number voted against him but he has
survived and joining me now is smp's
westminster leader ian blackburn mr
bradford your response to this vote
my heavens peers i have to say i'm
astonished at the scale of the rebellion
against the prime minister 148 mps a far
worse result than for example margaret
thatcher faced when she faced her
difficulties or theresa may faced and
when you think about it this is a prime
minister that can now only count on the
support of one-third of the members of
the house of commons you know i think
anybody else in the position that boris
johnson
is in today would recognize that the
game is up he's lost the moral authority
to lead he's lost the support of a
sizable percentage of his own party he
doesn't have the support of the house of
commons he's a man that i believe has
abused the office of prime minister with
his behavior and the sooner he goes the
better if he's not going to go tonight i
suspect that the pressure on him is
going to mount over the coming period
but i mean we know boris johnson and
he's very unlikely to go voluntarily and
the mechanism for removing him has now
been attempted
and he would argue has failed the rebels
have tried they didn't get enough he's
won he lives to fight another day how
will the system stop him continuing
well first and foremost pierce when
you've got a situation i mean you and i
understand how important loyalty to the
leader is in a parliamentary party but
when you've got more than 40 percent of
your own colleagues are prepared to vote
against you that is not a good look this
is going to make it extremely difficult
for him to command the support and trust
of his own party never mind the house of
commons it's a lame duck prime minister
and one that we know is going to face
very challenging circumstances and by
elections in the weeks to come so this
is not going to go away the tory party
will have to find its own mechanism but
of course we have the privileges
committee as well i believe that the
prime minister has not just lied to the
house he's broken the ministerial code
and we'll have to wait and see what
happens but this is not over there are
many hurdles for the prime minister to
get through we all know that he's had an
ability to escape the clutches of those
seeking to hold into account but in the
end this will end in the removal and the
failure of boris johnson's premiership
i mean give me an honest answer mr
bradford is it at the stage now where
you'd almost rather keep him in his
position because he's so damaged
well i understand why you say that i
understand why many people would say
that appears but at the end of the day i
think this man is a disgrace to the
office that he holds yeah i get the
point that some people would argue that
for us electorally is an asset but i
believe that this man is damaging our
democracy to such an extent it's in
nobody's interest to keep him in power
when you've got a prime minister that
broke the law the first prime minister
in history everything that's gone on
with his behavior and his behavior will
not change he treats downing street he
treats parliament as a personal
plaything we should be talking about
what's happening with the cost of living
crisis we should be talking about
ukraine but it always comes back to this
man boris johnson
and bradford thank you very much for
joining me
thank you peers well we have a reaction
now from
he's leader of the labour opposition
party
this evening
the conservative party had a decision to
make
to show some backbone
or to back boris johnson
the british public are fed up
fed up with a prime minister who
promises big but never delivers
fed up with a prime minister who's
presided over a culture of lies and law
breaking at the heart of government
fed up with a prime minister who is
utterly unfit for the great office that
he holds
well strong words there from sakia
stamina the opposition leader because he
himself is called up in an ongoing
police investigation into whether he
broke lockdown rules with beers and
curries and he's already said that he
along with his number two angelarona if
they are fined by police as boris
johnson was they will resign so we're
into pretty uncharted territory to bring
back the panel it's about i mean strong
words from kierstarma if he does not get
fined by the police he's in a very good
moral position on this i guess if he
does though he's gone
he is gone
and as ian blackford was saying there
are a number of hurdles still for the
prime minister i don't happen to think
those hurdles actually count for
anything because i don't think it
matters what any report says now what
any committee finds this is a prime
minister that is always going to try and
keep on brazening it out which he's sort
of managed to do fairly successfully so
far uh but you know
he's in a really really difficult
position now in terms of his legislative
program right uh i mean grace he is but
we do know he's not going to leave
voluntarily and we know he's one of
those guys that just barrels on through
and hopes for stuff to happen which then
distracts all our attention he's got a
track record of this yeah i mean this is
how he's governed so far it's been
government by distraction government by
spectacle this is the thing that he's
you know we're just hearing from anna
subrie that she thinks that he's
transformed the conservative party into
this nationalist populist project which
yeah is all about fighting culture wars
and he's done so relatively successfully
the big challenge that boris johnson and
the conservative party now as a whole
face is that there's a reason beyond
boris johnson you know as a person that
some of these mps have rebelled and that
is that they are concerned about the
future of the conservative party as a
free-market low-tax austerity-loving
party because they see that their
coalition has expanded they've you know
won some mps in the north of the country
where people rely on government spending
as we all do uh rely on public sector
spending to keep the economy to flow to
create jobs to boost investment and
there are a lot of mps now many of whom
are in the running for leader of the
conservative party who think that all
that is terrible it's a betrayal of
conservative principles we need to go
back to cuts cuts cuts we need to you
know shrink the state which by the way
is never actually about shrinking the
state it's about cutting spending for
the poor and cutting taxes for the rich
and uh get the conservative party back
to its kind of thatcherite very
unpopular position on a lot of these
things that's not going to work
electorally but there are a bunch of mps
who are very very committed to it esther
just quickly before go to the break if
it's not boris who should it be i mean
do you see anybody in the tory ranks who
you think exudes integrity honesty
decency the kind of things many people
feel i'm not fully lacking i'm not that
hopeful but you know the standard is so
low i mean the bar is in hell right so i
i think literally cucumber would have
more integrity than boris at this point
i i don't really buy the the excuse that
there's no one else find someone else
right find anyone else and put them
through the ranks because you cannot
have this man i mean let's see ben i see
ben wallace for example or tom tugan hat
people like this person
well penny morton maybe as well um i
listen to people like that and i i think
i hear people who appear to have
integrity i don't know enough about them
to really assess it but i don't think
this option there's no one out there who
can restore trust i don't think it's
true i think i think the bigger issue is
not just a single person it's about the
party and the principles that underpin
the party and the vision for the party
the current conservative party has no
vision it's not very conservative most
of the the current mps wouldn't even fit
into blair's government right because
they'd be too left-wing so i mean
there's literally you're not wrong this
is the interesting thing though because
we've got this idea that okay so there's
three marketeers who want to go back to
austerity basically and that's a battle
for the soul of the past that would be
an interesting actually political
discussion to have got to leave it there
for the break we'll be back with a
statement from boris johnson and also
the shadow justice secretary david lammy
will be here live after the race stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well you can get downing street live
here i'm joined by the shadow foreign
secretary david lammy uh mr lammy thank
you for joining me boris johnson's
calling this a very positive result very
inclusive result uh time to move on from
partygate it was all the media's fault
for spinning it etc your response
i think come on pierce
he's done worse than margaret thatcher
did in 1990 worse than john majored in
1995 worse than theresa may in 2018 all
of those prime ministers went on to lose
office yes they staggered on
wounded
uh badly wounded he's deeply wounded
deeply fought most of his back benches
are not with him that's what these
numbers demonstrate how can you go on to
properly govern a country in a time of a
cost of living crisis
huge rising inflation real concern
across the country how can you do that
realistically i think everyone knows the
game is up unfortunately the
conservatives should have taken taken
the mantle and got rid of him tonight
they haven't done that and so he limps
on but badly wounded at a time when the
country desperately needs proper
leadership we could be in an
extraordinary position where your own
leader and deputy leader
end up being fined by the police for the
beer corrigate night and they've already
announced if that happens they will
resign
but boris johnson who's already been
fined by the police
carries on
well look this isn't a question of
integrity it's a question of being
trustworthy
we've been raising this in the labour
party for months and months precisely
because the electorate we knock on their
doors have been saying they don't trust
this guy for his rule breaking how
they're now meant to trust him uh to fix
the economy and solve the cost of living
crisis that we've got of course they
don't trust him care has been absolutely
clear that of course he would resign if
he received a fine i've got to say as a
lawyer i've looked very closely at the
evidence i've spoken to other lawyers
he's not going to be fined um uh i don't
actually think this should have been
reinvestigated in the first place but
there we go uh he's been clear about
where he stands in the ground whatever
you say about him his integrity is
beyond reproach
what we've got here is a prime minister
and people can't believe him
and that's the fundamental problem
whatever you thought of margaret
thatcher uh whatever you thought of
david cameron whatever you thought of
john major there wasn't this essential
question of trust and lying in office
that's the test that boris johnson has
consistently not met and that's why his
back benches have deserted him tonight i
mean in a way i've asked this question a
few times in the last few minutes but
does labour even want boris johnson
to leave downing street now given how
damaged he is
it's not the fact that 148 of his own
mps have lost confidence in him one of
the best vote winners he could possibly
wish for
well look you might say that appears and
i understand why you might say that but
in a sense i think this is beyond
the partisan issue now it's way beyond
that it's this fundamental question of
trust and integrity in office i've got
the great privilege of being shadow
foreign secretary in the last few weeks
i've been in australia new zealand i've
been in washington uh and look people
consistently raising
the integrity of this guy what's going
on they've seen the rule breaking
you know they've seen his vacillations
over a period of time
the breaking up rules like the northern
ireland pro it's damaging it's damaging
for our image
publicly out there in the world that's
why we need to move on uh with a new
prime minister and the conservatives
really should have got rid of him
tonight david lammy thank you very much
for joining me thank you
well any statement boris johnson says
it's a convincing result a decisive
result and what it means is as a
government we can move on and focus
stuff actually matters to people i'm
grateful to colleagues i'm grateful for
the support they've given me and of
course i understand that what we need to
do now is come together as a government
as a party and that's exactly what we
can now do isabello shot your reaction
to boris johnson's jubilance tonight i
was dreading his statement it was always
going to be those words wasn't it it's
cringe i can't honestly it's just i want
to wince all of those words because none
of them are true and you know he knows
that doesn't he i was just thinking when
we were listening to david lammy there
of a scenario under which kia stammer
did have to resign has he actually said
he wouldn't re-run i don't know what the
labour rules are on that grace maybe
well i mean he quite clearly could rerun
um unless he decides to use that
opportunity or people decide to use the
opportunity to try and change the
membership rules again other the uh
votes
potentially put on the conservative
party wouldn't they if you had a leader
of the opposition and his deputy
potentially resigning on a point of
integrity and then re-standing it would
be well maybe
the best thing that could happen to the
labour party because if anything that
would be there would be a party of
integrity the conservatives can't even
say that now potentially actually
standing down and boris johnson standing
there at the same time would be a very
good thing for the labor party it would
actually also allow us to do what boris
johnson has allegedly said he wants us
to do which is focus on the issues that
matter rather than going back and forth
about who's dead who's alive you know
who stabbed him in the back we could
have a genuine conversation about how to
tackle the cost of living crisis in this
country which is actually what people i
think up and down the country are most
concerned about we're literally seeing
people unable to heat their homes unable
to pay for food and we've got this clown
in office diverting attention away from
those struggles so maybe that is what we
need because clearly the leader of the
country doesn't have an answer to those
problems and to be honest at this point
in time i don't have confidence that the
leader of the labour party has the
answers i want you all to have
confidence now in your predicting skills
who thinks boris johnson will still be
prime minister and tory leader by
september when the tory party conference
takes place isabella just yeah i think
he will be but not into the next
election right
i think he will be and i potentially
think that he'll be fighting the next
election i think he'll be gone before
the end of this year you do yeah
absolutely
i've got a feeling you might if not you
will see me at downing should be like
get out of here well i think one may
happen
you gotta remember the double whammy of
two by-elections on the same day is
quite unusual and if the polls are right
and the tories get completely taken out
in both of those by-elections that would
put a lot more heat on him than there
already is already i think you have to
remember that this is bigger than boris
johnson yeah as i've said multiple times
today this is an ideological question
that the conservative party has to
resolve and fundamentally they can't
resolve it while they're in government i
think that's an issue gotta live with
that thank you you've been a brilliant
panel thank you very much indeed for
being with me all night it's been a
fascinating night for british politics
boris johnson has survived
but maybe only for now he's claiming of
course total victory which is what he
would do but there are many people in
his own party who think not so fast mr
bond that's it from us tonight good
night and remember wherever you are this
particularly applies to you prime
minister
keep it uncensored
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]